so a one out free pass now keller to
face solaire 11 pitch coming
line and that's into right center field
and we'll roll deep and all the way to
the wall so solaire's long battle
results
in the game's first run arlo santana's
walk
leads to the two out rbi double and the
royals lead one nothing oh what up and
that bat
two on and two out facing hunter dozier
who is overdue and it's slammed into
left center field
that will roll all the way to the wall
solaire scores ben attendee scores
dozier is digging for three and he's in
there with a two out two run triple
yes
wait for yours
and the bulldozers back clearing the
bases
[Applause]
you could tell on contact that that was
in the right spot that's a slider just
floating up there it's a c mint mixer
that's all the ball does there that's
what they call it the cement mixer and
man perfect timing three-nothing kansas
city now mike miner will face the worst
team in the national league against
lefties
so far let's hope it works that way
and on a 3-2 pitch frazier strikes out
and there's one away
the wine and pitch a swing and a ground
ball to the right side fielded by
merrifield who's throwing plenty of time
and the royals take a three-nothing lead
and we'll go to the bottom of the second
a lead-off walk to todd frazier and now
the battle will be eric gonzalez
on the ground deep short nicky to second
for one and that's all the royals will
get that'll bring up lawrence native
jacob stallings
back through the middle but whit is
there out at second and this time the
royals turn a double play exactly what
mike miner wanted we head to the third
inning of play it's here salvi leading
off the third
here's a good-looking swing going the
other way and that's going to carry over
defoe salvi digs for second
and dives in head first he wants a
little that pnc dirt on him man ball
fours and that loads the bases for
michael a taylor
he will take a bases loaded walk
four-nothing royals
now it'll be nikki lopez
swinging the ground ball right to second
and onto short one relay two double play
well he walked in one but on the next
pitch popping gets out of it with a four
six three double play and the royals
lead is four nothing long way to go mike
miner back to work now the 1-1 from
minor swing and he pulls it to third
liner caught by a diving dozier at third
base and hunter dozier with those
cat-like reflexes makes the play for the
first out of the inning and now they are
loaded and how about this vanderbilt
matchup the tying runs gonna come up in
brian reynolds
called strike three outside corner big
strikeout right there for mike miner his
second strike out of the night and he
leaves him loaded to the fourth we go
and the royals have runners at the
corners with one out so let's see if the
royals can get some more here as salvi
will stand in salvi lines it to right
and that is going to sail over defoe who
got a bad read field scores
the royals lead 5-0 on
salvi's long single to right and so far
one run fourth inning with solaire who
has a double tonight
and solaire hits it into the air to
center and that's gonna drop for a base
hit santana comes in to score it's six
nothing
k.c
solaire with his second hit on the night
his ninth rbi benintendi has walked
three times tonight that has loaded the
bases that brings up hunter dozier
one is wrapped hard on the ground to
third one hop and gonzalez the second
one relay two double play one of the
most spectacular double plays you'll see
started by eric gonzalez that was
incredible that was incredible wow you
needed it that was big we needed it we
don't walk to todd frazier to eric
gonzalez who had that fine play and last
inning
drives this one deep to left field yeah
clear the deck with a big cannonball
see where that landed eric gonzalez a
monster shot
after
the spectacular double play was turned
crushed 453
feet and the batter now is
jacob stallings
and now stallings puts a charge into one
to deep left center field and
oh what a catch by michael taylor
oh my goodness what a play that was did
it catch or is it a home run
it's a home run he didn't catch it the
ball must have bounced overs over the
wall after it hit his glove and it's six
to three
he i think he pushed it over the wall
does he carry this over the offense
he's got it
and deposited
and he carried it over the wall yep
carried it over
excuse me almost lost his glove see that
the glove almost came off his hand
jacob stallings his first home run of
the season
with an assist from taylor pirates have
runners at the corners with one out and
now it's up to todd frazier who's walked
twice
hits this toward the right center field
gap and that ball is gonna get down this
is gonna score not only evans but
reynolds todd frazier
his first pirate hit is a rope into the
right center gap gets the pirates to
within one it's the royals six and the
pirates five jorge soler with two on and
one out
lined into right center field and jorge
soler is going to drive in at least one
more santana will hold it third and
jorge soler has three rbis their lead is
two it's 7-5 kc and the batter is ben
and tendy second and third one out
and ben attendee goes the other way
that's up the line and evans couldn't
get it on a slide
one run is home here comes solaire he'll
score
and it is a big inning
ben and tendy doubles in two
and the royals have three in the sixth
the pirates are coming about here in the
bottom of the eighth inning two out
double for frazier and now phillip evans
the pitch and the liner out to right
base hit for philip evans
and adam frazier's going to score don't
count out the bucks yet they put on
a run across make it 9-6 here in the
eighth we head to the ninth inning of
play earn his third save and get the
royals a split of the two-game
inner league series
stalling strikes out stamont has a one
two three bottom of the ninth and the
royals
who had scored only ten runs in their
previous four games
come up with nine runs on 12 hits